I have no filter I just I don't really
follow the to sterotypical rules Colton
Haynes is opening up like never before
he covers attitude magazines 25th
anniversary issue and says he went on a
downward spiral following his mom's
passing and his 2018 divorce from Jeff
Leatham after less than a year of
marriage you and Jeff are like couples
goals you know that right we really like
I didn't think that was ever gonna
happen I mean man
and then I was like what someone wants
to marry me goals it's like the craziest
thing and I was like yeah yeah I'll take
it he's that he's my my dream man Colton
says quote I got married and that didn't
work out that was extremely public and
heartbreaking and right when that was
going on my mom died and dad's I got so
heavily involved with drugs and alcohol
to mask the pain I was feeling that I
couldn't even make some decisions for
myself the 30 year old also says things
started getting dark for him after he
came out in 2016
he says the attention was making him
spin out of control like your way of
coming now do you feel like you need to
comment on your sexuality or you just I
think it's really just you know Colton
says rock bottom was when he woke up in
a hotel room with bruises all over his
body revealing he ended up in the
hospital on a 5150 psychiatric hold he
then sought help and entered treatment
for four months he left six months ago
and is still sober quote it's like this
rebirth I now feel things which is
something I not done for a decade I was
numb
[Music]